[Music]
lady why am i alive you are a toy you
belong to Bonnie these are your friends
woody I have a question um well actually
not just one I have all the questions
who wants to go on a road trip you need
help with that no no I got it
oh this is a little strange but we all
have to make sure nothing happens to
four key buzz we gotta get Roger that
[Music]
change of plans
Jesse hey let's go save a spork do I
need to be worried my guys are veterans
don't hang in there
Oh
I know the perfect toy to help
do kaboom Canada's greatest stuff man
oh yeah posing yeah hold on one more oh
yeah I've known that guy my whole life
today's
[Music]
oh is that how we look on the inside
there's so much body needs for you Oh
Sheriff what are you always come into
the rescue
that's gonna be quite a jump for you and
due committee
let's kaboom
[Music]
four keys being kept how do we get that
key what about the old plush rush there
you go oh where did you two come from
well we're not doing that
[Music]